and welcome to another edition of
beginner breakdown it's not really clear
what the show is I'm still analyzing
games for people but uh beginner
breakdown is in its final throes here
it's it's a dying show this is the
penultimate episode there will be one
more next week and then we'll move on to
strategy sessions so okay we got a
couple games here this one was submitted
to me so we'll go ahead and check it out
let's see the person said hi Jonathan
I like this game probably pretty simple
compared to your standards but I thought
it was a nice checkmate at the end so
we'll check it out and it looks like he
had the black pieces so that's what
we're gonna go ahead and and look at
here I wonder how do I look on this
screen this is normally where Ben Simon
pans slightly to the right so here goes
nothing
d4 okay excellent Knight f6 c4 e6 9c3
Bishop b4 so we know the name of this
opening nimzo-indian
okay and so the domain moves are either
III or Queens a c2 but it looks like his
opponent played Knight to f3 okay and
this can lead to the Kasbah Rauf
variation with an early g3 and it looks
like that did not happen because white
plays III on his next move alright so in
this game black castled so not the main
move which is c5 and just like the game
that I I showed I assume d5 and b6 or
probably also moves castling should be
fine
and now sort of a strange decision by
white white just played to move III
now in general when you're deciding what
to do with this bishop in the
nimzo-indian if black is already castled
it's usually a good idea to put this
bishop here sometimes that's not true
when they aren't castled because then
they're not afraid to play h6 and g5 and
drive the bishop away but once you've
castled playing h6 and g5 is really
risky it carries with it a lot of
weaknesses so that can make it very
difficult to play your position so in
general you should probably play here
first
you bring the bishop out and then play
e3 but that's not what was chosen so
this move probably shouldn't cause any
problems for black here and okay I don't
like blacks decision either black took
this unprovoked exactly so yeah this is
a move normally you might end up playing
but you should probably wait for white
to play a3 so once you play a3 then it
makes sense because you know you don't
want to waste any time but you don't
want to take a pin piece just to take a
pin piece so I would probably try to
exploit what black has here is he needs
to exploit his lead and development
that's his big trump and here he hasn't
even had to give up the two bishops yet
to achieve it so he's already castled
white is still two moves from castling
so again either c5 or d5 if I think some
sort of move creating some tension in
the center is called for here because
it's or black is is much more ready to
open up the position so if white doesn't
play carefully here you know you might
get to open the game wide open and the
King will still be on e1 so this
I didn't didn't particularly like and b6
okay I think this is good too you are in
this opening you're fighting for control
over a four so white is getting ready to
put a bishop on d3 and black will be
able to add one more defender of efore
so white wood usually like to be able to
play this move at some time in the
future so b6 makes sense and okay
another strategically dubious decision
d5 so straight away I see that you're
giving up the c5 square which looks like
a great square for my night yeah I don't
I don't think you should play d5 so soon
I think just Bishop d3 and castling is
is a good way to go
yeah just positionally this just doesn't
look very appealing and I don't like
what black did yeah he took this I don't
know I guess I would maybe if you guys
have like suggestions that's fine you
can let me know but I think d6 just you
know okay seems like something I'll do
if you ever take here I intend to take
back with a pond just have open the F
file that's that's fine for me and okay
and if you have your bishop here
occasionally I might like fork you but
okay but he took which helps that white
so now he this pawn still is is it over
extended or is it a thorn in blacks
position that's what we're gonna find
out but okay takes takes okay and now he
did play d6 which I think it's fine I
don't you are creating lots of
LightSquared weaknesses over on the
queenside I don't see a direct way for a
black or white to exploit it I mean if
somehow these guys disappear in this
night ends up in here then you might
have some problems or if his bishop is
able to come in here somehow
anyway you have some problems on the
light squares but this seems like a
normal enough move you intend to
maneuver the knight to c5 so that should
be fine h3 so his white really looks
worried about the threat of a pin
his black is black in the flight this
move I mean if I were black I don't
think I'd want to get rid of my
LightSquared bishop so if I make any
move here's white let me just like pass
for a second like is this fine like are
you really gonna give up this this
bishop and I can take with my queen I
suppose also I could take with my Jeep
on and then try to checkmate you I can
use the G file to my advantage but is
this really this is probably fine for
black but you know White has the two
bishops he does have a little bit more
space it's the only annoying thing is
that you have a c5 that's sort of bad
for me but I don't know about each day I
don't think that'd be the the first
thing on my radar because I don't really
think that the pain was a big threat but
okay alright we attacked the pun wait
defends it okay and here goes the night
so this guy actually might be blocked in
I think in this position I don't really
know where this guy wants to go because
obviously the way it happened in the
game I probably you know I try to get my
night out first because the way it
transpired here is it looks like now my
bishop has kind of blocked him but we
shall see we shall see maybe it's in
this position okay no yeah I was I was
thinking about about this move and okay
cuz hmm I don't know maybe I do want to
trade LightSquared bishop s' with you
mm-hmm yeah I'm trying to get the you
know the LightSquared bishop and then
when this guy moves out of the way you
know drop this guy in here or something
so maybe I do want to trade the bishops
with you yes I don't really know where
this guy goes yet so a lot of times
you're like you don't know where
somebody is gonna go but you know where
somebody else is gonna go this Knight is
somehow gonna make its way to c5 so this
is probably the piece that you should
grab first and okay there's two ways so
I think either of these moves make a lot
of sense because you know where that
Knights going he's going to c5 and it's
it's not clear this might be a good
square but I mean okay maybe this is you
know maybe it is at five but we won't
know just yet so you do need to be as
flexible as possible so I think this
move makes a little bit more sense here
but we saw this and after c4 Knight B to
d7 Bishop d3 and also I was wondering
where white was gonna put this Bishop so
when he puts it on if you put it on e 2
then your next move can just be castling
so here black does get to play this move
and it was played in the game and you
have to leave your natural diagonal to
preserve the bishop so okay very
interesting okay and I like this plan
for black guess what would you guys play
here as black cuz I actually like this
plan and I don't know what the oh this
was a like a correspondence game so I
think they had several days to make a
move it's like chess calm okay Bishop a6
you want to attack my pawn mm-hmm all
right I guess I'll protect it yeah so
you can put a knight here you can play
route to e8
yeah I don't think this is it's so bad
for you at all yeah your Knights are
kind of annoying they're really bugging
me yeah so I don't think this is a bad
move at all but I do like what was
played in the game and he played the
move
a six
with the idea and it looks like you did
actually play it of b5 and this is a
very typical way to undermine the Queen
side and in a lot of black openings you
should expect to see this when they play
the nimzo-indian in a lot of nibsy lines
you can even get away with playing a
move like b5 immediately so you'll see
it even sometimes early you know right
in the opening some of the first few
moves occasionally b5 is a nice you know
surprise weapon but it's something NIMS
a player should be aware of and I think
you can just play b5 straight away if
you if you'd like because if you take
here ok I'm taking here and if you don't
castle then I'm probably gonna stop you
from castling and okay I think this
would also be quite nice this guy is
potentially weak and also I can play
like a 6 and if you have to take then I
get the DA file and I'll try to target
this guy so and it but it looks like he
did it slightly slower but I mean I
don't think that's why any means a worse
way to do it but here he did it okay b5
okay so this this I do like I like how
Black has played this he took I'd be
looking for a way to not take
mm-hmm yeah so white probably knows yeah
if you're never gonna play the movie
forward and this is definitely the
diagonal for the bishop unless you want
to go here and take this Knight mm-hmm
but okay so here and you're just gonna
give me this and then also now you got
to worry about this guy I don't know
maybe there's nothing better than then
taking but feels like there should be
something see we take and he took back
and I move that surprises me
Queen d4 perhaps he's hoping for this
and this and this otherwise I don't know
I don't really know what the Queen's
doing there but okay maybe he's trying
to play you for okay it looks like okay
he's trying to play you for so you can
play rook e8 or any move let's see what
happens here okay obviously you can take
this and you took with the night all
right okay let's let's just think about
this though because now we have another
another dude here on e4 and if you ever
you know do end up playing this move
you're not threatening checkmate my
Knights actually pretty good on f6
because you do have that wide open
diagonal so it makes sense to have a
knight there that can block it but you
decided to take with us tonight so did
white threaten checkmate in one that's
the big question it takes should be to
it all right very good yeah maybe he
won't see it maybe he won't see it I
guess my first instinct to support my
knight back on f6 and had I done it with
a bishop then I wouldn't have to waste
all this time with my knight but he
found a different move
he played Queen f6 which I suppose
forces you to trade the Queen's so okay
he wants he wants to trade
yeah so wait wait here can and clearly
double him so this happened okay so this
move happened and here and he did not
play a bishop takes f6 so essentially I
mean black is up a pond and that is a
really nice Bishop so but let's let's
just go ahead and and have some fun I'm
thinking about taking this and then
being really confused after this move my
plan is to be really confused because
maybe white will take care and then I'm
gonna take here or I was gonna keep
taking stuff just keep taking and then
white gets to take the last thing and go
haha and then probably have to take here
and something takes bishop and you got
your pawn back and Wow
for isolated pawns I'm confusing and
then yeah as long as you don't do this
then then maybe you'll be fine but
obviously you don't even have to go in
for all that stuff after here you could
take back with your your pawn but a lot
of a lot of confusion would have been
sued which is probably two White's best
interest you should probably make the
position a little bit messy here cuz
otherwise black you know he's gonna end
up with strong control over efore he's
got the extra pawn eventually these
pawns on the Queen side are gonna matter
so I think yeah white should should
maybe think about taking that night
making it as messy as possible at least
if you get you know a weakness at least
if you have this on the board there's a
some weaknesses so you have something to
play for you go you got some control
over some of the like squares here you
can put a knight there'll be a good
night but he decided to play Knight d4
okay you attacked upon
and I think you could just play B for
that seems it seems fine but I I do like
this move if it if this works tactically
then I I quite like it bishop tv4 okay
so he took
and he took what this night
I feel like maybe I should take with the
other night because sometimes okay what
one waits planning let's see what
happened in the game we'll come right
back to it so his plan is is to try to
take this guy and then I wanted to take
advantage of the fact that you lined up
two pieces on this file so I want to
play one of my rooks here and then I
want to like trap your pieces I guess
this is the best but also with my knight
on f6 whichever way you decide to do
this you can always throw this move in
so I kind of want my knight to not be
there so I think you should maybe take
with this Knight
so now if you take here I think this
should win a piece a four I play Knight
takes a four and if you take here I can
play this and I'm attacking two pieces
so I think this this would have been a
little bit better okay instead he took
this way and white did take the bottom
okay
day to be eight okay so now he can take
on f6 which was played and I guess this
was blacks intention in this position he
took the night there and this this is
actually interesting because maybe you
don't have a really good square for this
Bishop I mean looking at it you can't go
here if he or I can kick you away can't
go here can't go here can't go here you
got only one square and mm-hmm
so actually yeah so maybe this is is a
bit strange and then you could play g5
they'll be like g5 after sit f3 and I'll
be like confused I don't know what's
going on so maybe that's possible but
also maybe you can even go this way and
try to create some some weaknesses I
don't think this is by any means force
but okay this guy might be an easy
target hopefully this guy is an easy
target also you might just leave the
bishop out there let's see if he if we
can just keep a little marooned Bishop
over here and we could also consider
just you know beginning to put pressure
on the weakness here so okay but let's
see what let's see what he actually did
just we'll see
he played the move c5 now you want to be
able to push your pawns and you have
passed pawns you want to push them you
just have to make sure you have enough
support so we'll will this pawn just go
like this or will some of these guys end
up being weak because I think what
happens a lot of times especially in
rook end games one of the best ways to
find a good plan is to look for the
weaknesses so whites should be looking
to attack this guy and black should
probably be looking to attack this guy
because it's very easy to see that I
okay I can tack this twice and just win
that pond so that also was very seems
like a very possible strategy and I even
have this knight to shield my pond if
there's a rook that goes there and I can
make you think about giving me an
exchange so even if you know I start
loading up here it's you know you know I
can put my rook here if I want to really
slow you down and okay I'll think about
pushing my pawns in a minute here I also
might have some tactics
I don't know but yeah I think that
normally in these these rook end games
you want to find the weaknesses and just
attack him with your rooks and it's
blacks turn so maybe he could get there
faster than his opponent but okay
c5 was played so we'll see maybe this is
fine as well d1 okay so very good bye
bye wait he's going after the weakness
and black just kept going so white
decides all remove the defender all
right I think that's that's very good
move now you got to move away and then I
get to take your pawn to c3 and he took
the pawn
so I think this is just starting to slip
away for black here
although okay you might be able to get a
rook to the second rank really fast you
played this move after King f1 you don't
have a whole lot of squares I mean you
probably didn't do this to go back so in
he went rook c6 is very good right he's
sorry he's doing a great job attacking
the weaknesses c3 which is also funny
because that was the only square you and
I can go to see your knight might end up
getting trapped unless your opponent
plays the move that was played so I
don't know maybe then yeah yeah I'm
trying to trying to make sure that I
can't just push my pawn but it looks
like now you've trapped your knight
so what what happens here in the game
okay this move was played and now you
can escape I understand you have the
majority over there so you do want to
push those pawns but with a knight so
far in your territory you want to see if
you can trap them and that that just
looks like a good move a poor time to do
this you wanted to save your pawn but it
just doesn't work tactically but uh okay
he he kind of helped you out now black
is back in the game so I think I think
you should just push this instead h6 I
don't know I mean are you just gonna
play g5 and the bishop will go to a
better diagonal this guy's not very well
placed I don't know how he wants to come
into the game somewhere else I don't
really know the point it's not like you
have an immediate back rank issue maybe
you should just push here
because okay so obviously if you take
this eye queen with check so I don't I
don't really I don't know it would do
here but I you know it feels like you
should do that and then your knight can
escape if it's untouchable for now so
hopefully it can hit escape and you can
bring your other rook in but instead we
saw each six Bishop f2 all right so he's
got control over d4 again and by
playbook to DA okay that's good so now
my Knights not getting trapped Bishop e3
the black one for up d3
Bishop c1 and okay this looks like this
looks like we're here you made is he
said he had a good checkmate
so it looks like this is where it begins
so yeah okay I agree so white is getting
checkmate it here we'll see it is we'll
see if people can figure it out you know
it feels so this I mean blocking this is
a big mistake
rookie one obviously is check I agree
with that statement okay right and then
the I can run away I don't know where
and then you can you go you take the
rook so this it's also looks winning
unless I can take this nice or in this
position
my g3 okay this move this move was
played kingi one rookie one night f1 you
in here
man okay I think yeah you actually went
to h1 but I don't think it makes a
difference and then draw 93 excellent
yeah so that really was a fantastic
checkmate there that was that was very
nice
yeah so if we go back to this move this
was so let's just ponder it mate and you
know it is a tricky mate to find because
you yeah you might be thinking okay I'll
give this check something like that but
a very nice find by the player with the
black pieces here
Knight to g3 and one more time you slow
it down Bensimon slow motion
very nice checkmate and that's the end
of the game okay yeah so I think you
know sort of in the opening both players
played strategically suspicious moves
but in the middle game I think black
showed a good understanding when he went
for the b5 break he played a 6 and b5
and sort of broke down the queenside and
ultimately he won upon and then I think
you miss played a little bit and then
white blundered and he checkmated him so
that was a really nice game that was
actually quite an entertaining one I
really liked looking at it and we'll
have a look at one more game and Greg
who last week we went over one of his
games yeah he sent in another game so
the last game he played we'd get the the
Sicilian it was a classical Sicilian and
Greg is white again and so this is
interesting too so the first game he
played efore and now in this game he's
playing d4 excuse me and I think that's
a really good sign I like when people
are willing to play E 4 and d4 I think
it's really important to improve your
chest you sort of play a really wide
range of openings I know some people
sometimes get afraid they're like oh I
know e for so well I barely know d4 and
then they never play it but you can
actually borrow from other
so to really improve your understanding
of chess as a whole you do kind of need
to branch out and try all sorts of
different things so already this is a
good sign
okay g6 so will this be a King's Indian
will it be a prune fold alright
so possibly a King's Indian and very
interesting so e4 is the the main move
here he decides to play the fianchetto
variation and I had played this for a
while as well because I lost to a very
strong player and mostly that's how my
repertoire works a really strong player
beats me with some opening and then it
looks like the opening is like
invincible and then I play it and then
you know usually I do well so when
you're the higher rated player in some
situation you might be influencing the
opening choice of your opponent for a
long time because I see you play
something it worked so well and then
they just keep playing it so that can
happen and c6 okay so black is probably
think about playing d5 Bishop g2 and
Knight a six-night to a6 perhaps he's
gonna go to c7 and then play d5 I don't
I think yeah if you just play d5 you get
sort of a Greenfeld position where
you've avoided any early exchanges on d5
so you can always support your center
with a pawn 96 I'm unfamiliar with but
uh okay I don't really like White's
choice here I think you should just play
like e4 or this looks pretty good and
you might even be be threatened in e5
here so black would have to do something
about this he played the move a3 which I
don't know is he trying to prevent his
opponent from going to beat four
that's probably not a threat you need to
worry about because everything he plays
the knight to be four you can always
play a3 kick them back
we'll see a little rook to b8 so a
little bit unorthodox so not my castling
not d5 d6 or some some sort of normal
move perhaps you think he's gonna play
b5 I guess I guess he's gonna play b5
which this is something that you
sometimes do but normally this doesn't
happen so early but uh you didn't get
off this diagonal that's that's one good
thing we can say and b4 okay you get
more space on the queenside oh yeah I
again don't really understand why e4
wasn't played I think I think you should
just play in the center because looks
pretty good and they need to help unite
and Castle and you know eventually in
the future I'm gonna do this and this
and I'm gonna go like this and this and
this so b4 and I think white is much
better so it's not like I had I'd
complain about this too much so I think
I would play e4 but uh you win here
which is not my my first instinct
because well the move that was played in
the game but also I mean if they're
they're gonna kick you around
are you really intending to take that
night in the game black played the
funnier way to attack the bishop which
is what's the funnier way to attack the
Bishop h6 is the obvious way but he's
playing against a crazy person so Knight
to e6 yeah you're not even on the radar
alright so some interesting night
maneuvers this is a not a maneuver you
see in the textbooks and
yeah he took he took care now if it were
me I assume the computer wants you to
take this off but I seen before me I
would just go back I was joking
you can have your night on e6 like I
don't care you can have it I think when
people should play a real goofy like
this you can expect them to continue to
do goofy stuff and so I probably just go
back and you know I'll let you have your
night on e6 that's that's your problem
but he took here so black black now has
the two bishops he's gonna assuming he
took it we don't know that yeah
he might he might not have taken it
wouldn't you take with a pun he took
with the bishop I mean you perhaps could
take with the pond you know and you'll
eventually play f5 so your bishop has
some scope and yeah if you did this and
you you played f5 oh I mean it yellow
somehow then you know you'd be you'd
have some targets here and now the
knight isn't on in front of a pond so
actually taking what the pond is is an
interesting idea he took with the bishop
so maintaining the pawn structure III
okay the pond is attacked III the next I
just wanted you know develop my knight
and Castle and then I'll start my attack
now who can guess what black play
alright this guy hasn't moved enough yet
so what would be the last where I'd move
this night to I don't know okay the
night went over to g5 so here's the
here's the maneuver that's how you
maneuver your Knights around in chess I
don't I don't normally see at night on
g5 that's not a square I don't think of
that Square as a square for a knight
unless it's a white knight because then
sometimes that makes sense you don't see
a black knight here on this square very
often and it looks like he was kind of
helping him out
he put his knight on f3
now if my opponent did this maneuver
with his Knight I don't want to trade
for his Knight because he doesn't know
how to use his knights you know so I
think when he puts this knight here I
mean maybe you can just just go here
this seems also fine and you castle but
by going here you're allowing black to
trade which didn't happen but he doesn't
know how to use that night so I think
trading it off is a mistake giving him
the option and then you would have to
figure out how to take back and then he
sort of solved the problem of his oddly
placed night you also might think of a
move like h4 or something just to kick
him away but he went here and the knight
did not move but I played h6 so what
happens if I take his Knight usually
yeah I'm gonna do this and well you want
to take this way yes okay so far but are
your pawns gonna be so pretty after this
move you know so yeah you could do this
and if I want I'll take this hmm I don't
know I mean it's probably not so bad the
game isn't as one-sided as maybe it
could be but also if you like to play
Tetris you could you could go in for
this variation because you know so if if
chess isn't your game and you prefer
Tetris this might be the formation for
you so yeah that would have been
interesting so I think you white could
have probably taken the night or if for
me I'm like you know I'm not trading
with you but uh did he take
let me castled okay also reasonable and
the bishop retreated
so it is I mean I do kind of also want I
I kind of want to take it but I also
kind of want to move and play h4 just to
kick it back but taking it should be
fine even though black does get the the
H file I don't see any immediate way for
that to be exploited and we played a
very interesting move here f4 again I'm
wondering what happens on Knight e4
because are you really gonna play a move
like f6 you might maybe that's not so
bad but it doesn't make kind of a funny
impression mm-hmm yeah and I can this is
a pawn that I can target I can go here
sometimes I can go here this this would
be interesting and the game he went f4
and what crazy thing did black do oh
good he did something unexpected yeah
you would he would see that coming so
your opponent would see that one coming
you'd have to be sane and like want to
get rid of your double pawns
that's what a normal person would do but
we're dealing with a crazy person here
he pushed a pawn I don't know if that's
the one you were thinking of where you
that you're thinking of g4 oh yeah e6
and all right yeah I don't think black
likes White's next move
so this what did white play here this
looks like is a pretty good move
remember White's the normal one but I
like the move that he played so instead
of putting a pawn on e4 when you don't
put your pawns on e4 you can put your
pieces on e4 so that happens in a lot of
openings whenever you have you know your
pawns on e3 and d4 it's very common that
a piece is the one that's gonna land on
the e4 square so this happens a lot in
d4 openings a much less so in the e4
openings because you put upon on e4
but in d4 openings it's it's pretty
common to use the e4 square for your
pieces rather than your your pawn and
now we got two threats here
so you want to get checked or don't me
take your pawn let's see what he went in
for he went for d5 this move was played
okay which might be the right decision
let's let's instead let's do something a
little bit different just to see what
the alternative was okay maybe I don't
want to lose my pawn so n we come and f8
is the safest but this is the craziest
okay even to move like c5 is fine
and there's some some way I can sack my
night and let you take it but okay I
mean even yeah I'm gonna move like this
looks it looks very good and okay this
is the same you know you can just move
like this is fine
may I take this pawn I thought I'm
threatening here so actually
can I can I go well let's let's play
this variation I want to see if I can go
here and if you go here I go here yeah I
mean I said yeah you go back I mean I
just assume I have enough compensation
here somehow some way so I mean the
probably has some sort of like crazy
stuff but even you know just supporting
the pond seems sufficient to give away
the a big advantage here so it makes
sense I mean you know what that night
dropping in on d6 so his move was d5 and
he took the pond okay
and he just hard to play black here but
this is beginner breakdown so he played
the move that we know not to play
because it's beginner breakdown blade f6
which is not allowed in this class so
there's that and okay here and I should
read what he he wrote he said second
game I was in a bit of time trouble
after calculating intensively my sack so
here he sacrifices so it's interesting
so the movie played was he took on d5
I'm wondering also about this sacrifice
with the point that I'm taking this it
also looks very good
if you run to the F file I mean I'm
taking this and I don't know my rooks
coming in okay so the alternative is
here and I mean I mean taking this might
just be enough you better the bishop
yeah okay so let's let's try to let's
try to be greedy and then like mate this
guy is sorry actually maybe this move
actually maybe the computer smarter than
me maybe this move because I can play
here or here the computer wants you to
do your queen which means it's not right
wait a minute when you go there I'm
gonna take you yeah if I know yeah okay
so it looks like there's a lot of things
I mean this also looks interesting as
well I'm just gonna play here checkmate
and so maybe you have to play Queen
takes rook so that's that's also game
over yeah I don't I don't think he's in
good shape and so here instead he took
with the pun and so I guess the point is
he's gonna take on c6 so let's see if we
we saw him go ahead and grab this guy
okay so so far it's two pawns
for the the piece and you are opening up
the game which is very good for white
because black is having some difficulty
developing his pieces and here I really
I really don't like this move the black
played I I don't think he should be the
one opening up the position so this is
also just a trade but you're opening you
know the F file so now
rook takes was played you know you it's
not you trade either way material is the
same whether black trades or white
trades but at least if white trades then
you take with your clean and you're
threatening III and at least you're
getting some of your pieces out but
opening it up looks a bit suspicious the
rook took and Queen c7 and now he did go
after the g6 pawned and he went to d3 so
I'm wondering why he didn't go to c2 I
suppose one of the differences is that
now you can you can be able to play this
movie so now you're pinned but also I'm
I'm also trying to prevent you from
taking here because now I think this
would be quite good for me because I'm
even here I mean I can take this guy
some bad some bad stuff is happening but
he went to d3 which also should be a
good move rook h6 already protected his
thing I mean this is this is just bad ok
White's playing very well here so yeah I
think this the sacrifice is probably
sound
I mean I'd really prefer to be white
here I don't think I want the extra 1
point of material in this position so
now he took okay so my as Queen was on
c2 I'd be able to play Bishop takes c6
but okay he attacked to that pawn again
that's a good idea so he's doing a good
idea he identified a weakness and he's
targeting it so very good g5 all right
yeah this move that was play it looks
like bad news that doesn't make me feel
good what would you play here it's
actually interesting what would you play
her mm-hmm so this wasn't played but I
think I think this makes a lot of sense
and yeah it just wins the bishop but
material I'm you know you're only up a
pawn as white but you have a lot of
threats you're gonna go like here and
here I mean you know you have a lot of
threats here your pieces are really
active so I do like this continuation
but it wasn't played maybe his way is
also fine so this is what was played and
then I'm gonna put my my guy here but
you never know you never know that
doesn't look like that's his intention
here
that was so okay and so he's gonna pick
up the Queen and I don't see anything
more brilliant than taking the Queen so
that all happened so now it's it's two
rooks versus a queen I don't know this
is you know it just kind of feels like a
Whitehead had so much more now you've
you've liquidated all of your attacking
pieces so yeah I think yeah going back I
really like this move a lot more because
and you don't really want to be trading
lots of material I guess I mean you're
winning a little bit material but
keeping your active pieces it's a lot
more important here because black is
under tremendous pressure so I think in
the game variation you've really sort of
lost the pressure in the position let's
see here
Queen c2 all right he's gonna play
Bishop b4 he's gonna attack the pond
ship d7 and you know he can double on
the h-file Bishop b4 was played black
Thomas on the each file I mean this is
not such a simple task right it felt
like you know he's just crushing them
you're attacking them and doesn't
doesn't really feel that way anymore I
do like his move though I suppose
there's probably a lot of good moves
here I'm wondering what you guys would
come up with but I do like his move and
the green c5 it looks like a good square
for the Queen you know there's so many
checks maybe five first let's see what
his what his opponent come up with here
he took here right yeah yeah this bishop
is well placed in this position so
that's gonna be the one problem for
black here I don't know how black
continues to make inroads to the King
here so your your King is actually quite
safe somehow you have to play this move
and then like just train them some sort
of atomic chess and like they explode
and then then you maybe you can made
them but even then the King still
probably runs away either Queen a7 check
the move takes all right me too
it sort of Greg
I like I like this move actually you
know you're keeping the pieces on the
board the king went back this way and I
really like White's move here move of
the game right here this and the the
sacrifice to begin with so here a really
nice move by white to see what you guys
would will come up with in this position
because I think once you see this move
it's it's sort of a lot of trouble for
black here no I mean there's probably a
lot of good moves
yeah b5 so that was played and this
looks really good
he didn't end up taking it and ok you
can
he continued to play well what would you
guys play here yeah Queen b6 was played
and it looks like you're threatening
mate and it looks like his opponent
didn't do very much about it so you he
went here not that there's much you can
do about it but okay you went here and
now there's a typical mating pattern and
so that that L happens
does anyone see the mate here do you see
it guy walking in the room now shaking
his head he's got no idea right you go
we got a perpetual right yeah we're
gonna go here and then we'll even go
there and then we'll draw yeah okay this
move did happen and hopefully everybody
at home can see the checkmate it's a
very common pattern here
Bishop to c6 there's quicker than that
oh well dish' basics right I wanted it
at all okay so this this would have
happened and it looks like this this did
happen in the game and it was here that
I black resigned so okay yeah that's not
the same same thing yay
so yeah that was that was great that was
an excellent game your opponent played
really goofy in the beginning he played
all sorts of strange moves especially
with the Queen
it went on a long tour all around the
board and you had sort of a really big
advantage
I do think you've made a mistake in the
middle game trading off all the pieces
because that made it a little bit
tougher but okay you were still a lot
better in that ending and you proved it
and you were able to win the game so
thanks to the two people that sent in
the games last next week will be the
last beginner breakdown ever
so I know and so I'll be seeing you guys
next week so you can keep sending in
your games and thank you very much